IT, BRET.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN, THANKS.
IF THERE'S WORD TONIGHT THAT THE
SON OF OSAMA BIN LADEN IS DEAD.
MULTIPLE NEWS OUTLETS CITING
U.S. OFFICIALS AS CONFIRMING THE
DEATH, BUT THEY ARE NOT SAYING
HOW IT HAPPENED OR WHETHER THE
U.S. WAS INVOLVED.
HE WAS CONSIDERED AN EVENTUAL
SUCCESSOR TO HIS FATHER, WHILE
BEASLEY MASTERMINDED THE 9/11
TERROR ATTACKS IN 2001 AND WAS
KILLED BY U.S. TROOPS IN 2011.
LUCAS TOMLINSON HAS THE
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT FROM THE
PENTAGON.
GOOD EVENING, LUCAS.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
U.S. PLACED A A $1 MILLION
BOUNTY ON BIN LADEN IN FEBRUARY,
DETAILS OF HIS REPORTED DEATH
REMAIN A MYSTERY.
JOHN ROBERTS ASKED THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT IT EARLIER.
>> TO HAVE ANY INTELLIGENCE THAT
IT BIN LADEN'S SON HAS BEEN
KILLED?
>> I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT ON
IT.
I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, EVERYBODY.
>> THREATEN REVENGE AFTER NAVY
SEALS KILLED KILLED HIS FATHER,
AL QAEDA MASTERMIND OSAMA
BIN LADEN IN PAKISTAN IN 2011.
U.S. INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO
HIM AS AN EMERGING LEADER OF
AL QAEDA WHO CARRIED OUT THE
WORST TERROR ATTACK ON AMERICANS
SOIL.
OTHER AL QAEDA WILL RESPOND TO
IRAN.
THEY WERE DETAINED BUT LATER LET
GO.
OVER THE YEARS, HE RELEASED
AUDIO AND VIDEO MESSAGES CALLING
ON SUPPORTERS TO LAUNCH ATTACKS
AGAINST U.S. AND ALLIES AROUND
THE WORLD.
HAMZA IS THOUGHT TO BE 30 YEARS
OLD.
IF U.S. GOVERNMENT SAYS HE
MARRIED THE DAUGHTER OF A SENIOR
AL QAEDA LEADER WHO WAS INDICTED
BY A FEDERAL GRAND JURY FOR HIS
ROLE IN THE 1998 TERRORIST
ATTACKS AGAINST TWO U.S.
EMBASSIES IN TANZANIA AND KENYA.
A VIDEO OF HAMZA'S WEDDING WAS
FOUND OSAMA BIN LADEN'S COMPOUND
IN A PAKISTAN RAID AND RELEASED
BY THE CIA TWO YEARS AGO.
OTHER DOCUMENTS SEIZED INDICATE
BIN LADEN WAS GROOMING HIS SON
TO REPLACE HIM AS LEADER OF
AL QAEDA.
NAVY SEALs KILLED ANOTHER SUN
DURING THE RAID IN ADDITION TO
HIS FATHER.
THE CIA CONTINUES TO CUT     HUN
THE CIA CONTINUES TO CUT     HUT
THE CIA CONTINUES TO CUT     HUD
THE CIA CONTINUES TO CUT     HUW